so blue seed is a solution to a problem
the problem is that Silicon Valley
hungers today for technology companies
great ideas great innovators but it
doesn't have access to them when they
come from other parts of the world right
now the USA's visa immigration system
does not allow for entrepreneurs to come
here and test out their ideas and create
the new jobs and create the new
companies of tomorrow perhaps the next
Facebook about tomorrow because of its
system was designed for a sort of bygone
era an era that was dominated by large
companies looking to bring in personnel
not an era dominated by the sort of
economic growth and the sort of
companies and startups that we see in
the technology sector today blue state
is creating a visa-free technology
incubator for startups twelve miles
outside the coast of Silicon Valley on a
ship it is a place where entrepreneurs
will be able to come from any part of
the world and connects in to Silicon
Valley's ecosystem and create the
companies and create the technologies of
tomorrow and once these ins of these
companies grow large enough they become
well financed five million dollar ten
million dollar companies they'll be
moving into Silicon Valley and joining
the entire culture paying taxes creating
jobs doing all the things that that
Tilikum valley companies do one way of
describing what makes Silicon Valley so
special is the fact that it's so
intrapreneurial that the goal in Silicon
Valley is to find novel solutions to an
existing problem or even better create
whole new end industries economic growth
is at the heart of prosperity it's what
causes us to live the wonderful lives
that we live and it's what brings so
many people around the world out of
poverty and at the heart of economic
growth is entrepreneurship it's people
coming up with new ideas new
technologies sometimes that
entrepreneurship takes place within
companies such as Google which has a
very entrepreneurial culture sometimes
it takes place outside of companies by
individuals who are creating new
companies new technologies bringing new
ideas to the market this is a good
solution for all of the parties involved
foreigners will be able to come closer
to Silicon Valley Silicon Valley in
American economy
be able to basically benefit from these
new companies new ideas and maybe even
new industries and so that is what blue
seat is enabling it's enabling
individuals to come here and create the
companies and create the jobs and create
the technologies that will not just get
us out of this rut but provide us with
the runway that that propels us into the
future economically